I have a great heart for these folks
we're talking about a great love for
them and people think in terms of
children but they're really young adults
I have a love for these people and
hopefully now Congress will be able to
help them and do it properly that was
President Trump earlier today talking
about his plan to rescind daca a policy
of course implemented by then President
Obama without congressional approval and
it extends protections to certain
illegal immigrants who enter the United
States before their 60th birthday now
the president is urging Congress to find
a constitutional solution to daca which
will come to an end in six months
joining us now with reaction is the
anchor of America on fusion Jorge Ramos
all right let me let me go to the
president's remarks today and he said we
expect people in this country to play by
the rules
we expect that those who cut the line
will not be unfairly rewarded and that
for the time being you'll be able to
stay in this country without fear of
deportation and get right with the law
that's what the law is do you have any
problem with what the president said I
do I have many problems with what the
president said first of all you cannot
trust the president he said that he
loved the dreamers and he also said that
dreamers shouldn't be very worried well
guess what happened immediately after he
said that just a few days or weeks after
he said that he's basically throwing
them out of this country now I do
understand that they are here illegally
of course they came here when they were
babies when they were children and to no
fault of their own
you have kids Sean I have kids and many
times they are not responsible for the
things that we do so I think the most
important responsibility that we have as
parents and as citizens is to take care
of our children impressive and from deep
we can take care of the world's children
you Jorge I love you have your warm
heart I admire that I care about you you
helped a lot of people a lot of
immigrants Sean I do know that I do and
I listen I'll be honest I only want the
best for people and I'd like other
countries to now step up and do their
job one of the worst people that the
worst treatment of immigrants
from Mexico if you're from Central
America El Salvador Nicaragua Honduras
you're treated horribly it's terrible
but here's what the but you I'm sure you
also agree with me on this point we are
a nation of laws and we have a
constitution and we have co-equal
branches of government President Obama
as I played his own words he didn't
believe constitutionally he had the
authority to assert the power of
Congress but he did it anyway
so what President Trump is now doing is
saying all right you had eight months
Congress I'm going to give you six more
months and if you want to fix daca do it
legally if you don't want to fix it we
can usurp the Constitution yeah but then
who's going to take care of them they
are already here Sean you know they're
already here they came here again when
they were very young 800,000 of them and
if you are don't worry you know I'm glad
for that way then you're really know so
someone has to take care of them and it
is our responsibility to do that I think
what President Trump DS was what I read
you earlier is one hearted and when I
read you earlier I was from Obama what I
read you at the beginning of the segment
was from Obama and Obama is the one that
said you can apply to stay temporarily
this was meant to be temporary
now President Trump rightly so is
following co-equal branches of
government he's saying to the Congress
go do your job I'm giving you more time
you've already has a different under
Obama he's not the president
he's not protecting the dreamers and
they are not Americans they are
Samaritans as Trump's children exactly
the same the only difference John is
that they don't have a paper to or
Howard you cannot ask that the United
States burn its constitution stomp all
over it in the process of doing what you
want you have to understand what I want
relational we were showing when we're
talking about children who are already
here I understand that they're here
illegally children on mature and here
legally but if you're negative I know
the good news are you Jorge is not there
log it is not there for Sean you do
understand I hire you or your whistle
may boy really it has to know I do
listen burn the Constitution just to do
it okay
once you've got to do it legally we get
we can absolutely but we can change the
law President Reagan did in 1986 why
can't we do it in 2017 now my concern my
real concern we should build the wall so
people don't come in illegally again III
don't think I don't think a world will
help because as you know on the watch
general immigrants convoy or with a visa
but my concern is that I get a Rolo sub
a path yeah I know you have to go but
this follows a path which is president
from calling Mexican immigrants rapists
and then one in the wall I'm hoarding or
were you and now we're handing you
should be that Jorge
he's given Congress eight months to do
their job he's given them an additional
six months yeah he didn't call progress
and try me well I put that on my show no
you get across president from wait a
minute I when he said he said he had my
card Jorge others no we get away from
that meeting I'm sorry about that heart
immigrants rapists
there have been the illegals that have
raped and murdered sir very few we need
very few thing well it happen within
mothers and fathers have lost their kids
for a to in England emigrants adult
reenactor a lot to them to every night
to protect them and their fam I always
think to them toward that I am really
sorry for what they went through and
they shouldn't be leaving that show I do
understand what happening whether that's
my paper I get a ton of a piss or
criminal the vast majority miles or
vapor a a small percentage of you is
just hundred and twenty two thousand
crimes committed by illegals just a
matter for your period intact immigrants
are less likely immigrants are less
likely to be criminal than those born
here in the United you don't care about
the six hundred forty two thousand was
committed against Isis listen to me a
show them for yes I do understand yes I
do understand yeah but it's just a small
minor go when you portrayed everyone as
criminals it is not fair together all
right I agree to disagree thank you for
being with us all week